[主播] 器官的重要组成部分啊。
[主播] DHA，我们以前说让孩子多吃鱼，其实就是鱼里头含有DHA，Omega3的家族或者EPA，大家知道EPA就是就是鱼油的意思啊。
[主播] 所以这就是为什么要读历史。
[主播] 那那个咱现在有
[嘉宾] 没有了。
[主播] 明朝那些事。
[主播] 鸡蛋没有了是吧？
[主播] 鸡蛋没有了没事。
[主播] 这个明朝那些事还有吗？
[嘉宾] 应该有。
[主播] 有你谈一下。
[主播] 那一套书它的优点就在于我们当然不能把它当做一个严实的严肃的正式去看。
[主播] 但是它的大量的史实是基本符合史实的。
[主播] 还有一个就是它是可以比较深入浅出的去做学问，去讲历史的。
[主播] 这个很重要。
[主播] 板着脸去做学问是容易的。
[主播] 你看很多老师就是板着脸在讲课，你管我讲的有没有趣，总之只要你没有听懂，我就说你不行。
[主播] 只要你没有做对，我就说你是你懒。
[主播] 只要你做考的差，我就说你是我带过最差的一届学生。
[主播] 当然很容易。
[主播] 我是老师如果指责学生，其实是站在了一个舆论的制高点上去指责那些没有还手之力的人。
[主播] 就像那些华尔街的精英要去指责那些在田地里种地的人一样，那种感觉。
[主播] 所以我以前在当老师的时候，我也给
[主播] 因为我曾经是高中语文的这个教研主管，我曾经就要求我们的老师，我说只要学生不听就是你的问题。
[主播] 只要学生听不懂，也是你的问题。
[主播] 只要学生做不对，更是你的问题。
[主播] 所以我以前就去听他们的课。
[主播] 我听完了之后我给他反馈，我说你这课听完了之后，我都不知道该做啥笔记。
[主播] 你能不能设计清楚？
[主播] 所以后来大家知道这个板书是要边写边擦，但是剩下部分要留的。
[主播] 第二次我就听完了，他说板书怎么样？
[主播] 我说板书倒是可以，你这节课讲的太无趣了，我听不下去，我一直瞌睡。
[主播] 好，他就知道要让自己的课去味性强。
[主播] 然后第三次去味性也强了，板书也有了。
[主播] 我说你这节课你真的听给学生讲明白？
[主播] 他说明白。
[主播] 我说你怎么知道明白？
[主播] 他说我就会讲明白。
[主播] 我说学生做对才是做明白。
[主播] 所以他要开始设计练习题。
[主播] 所以我刚所讲的这个，其实就是一个老师想把课讲明白是要花心思的。
[主播] 那同样的，一个作家要把一本书写清楚，把一段历史讲明白也是需要花心思的。
[主播] 板着脸去做学问，去要求别人，站在一个相对的高高地上指责如老师指责学生一样，是容易的。
[主播] 那聪明的老师或者负责任的老师他会想办法让课变得有趣。
[主播] 那聪明的或者负责任的这个作者也会想办法让他的书变得能够让你容易读懂。
[主播] 让你能够循循善诱的，一直深入读下去。
[主播] 这就是明朝那些事这套书的优点。
[主播] 所以直到现在他为什么在大全国大学的图书馆的借阅榜里头仍然能够排到非常靠前的位置。
[主播] 经常处于前五啊。
[主播] 你敢信？
[主播] 活了这么多年了。
[主播] 你像平凡的世界不是也是活了这么多年了。
[主播] 活着也活了这么多年了。
[主播] 经典东西一直火。
[主播] 就是因为它好。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 所以读历史。
[主播] 我们能够去研究一段历史的兴衰的时候，我们能够去研究很多民族的兴衰的时候，
[主播] 我们的子孙也会更加的清醒，理智，充满了远见。
[主播] 我之前说悲观是远见，但是乐观是智慧。
[主播] 这句话我觉得说的很有道理。
[主播] 孩子们能够完整地去看待历史，想到未来也不会一番风顺，但是他们可以去乐观的计划，去乐观的执行。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 所以为什么要读历史？
[主播] 读完了历史要干嘛？
[主播] 读完了历史的时候，下一个其实你应该去读一读哲学了。
[主播] 因为历史中人们发展的一个核心主题，除了建立强盛的帝国以外，还有一个其实就是人文历史，对吧？
[主播] 那人总要去寻求自己的。
[主播] 西方2000年你可以总结为什么？你可以总结为从苏格拉底提出了知识即美德之后，
[主播] 人们越来越关注知识，总结现象，研究规律。
[主播] 人们觉得自己痛苦的发现自己的脆弱和无知之后，人们想要从那些神秘的遥不可及的变幻莫测的事情中寻求精神动力。
[主播] 所以他们就愿意信那些东西。
[主播] 但是你发现在我们这边土地上，人们很少信那些东西。
[主播] 道教有吗？
[主播] 有。
[主播] 但是道教里头有特别全的这种强烈的神论吗？
[主播] 他会具体到一个人上吗？
[主播] 没有。
[主播] 佛教也进来过，对吗？
[主播] 但佛教跟那些是不一样的。
[主播] 然后呢，你会发现从不管是这个诸子百家，到后来这个黄老学，对吧？
[主播] 八出百家独尊儒术，还有这个文景之治时的黄老学。
[主播] 它其实是一种非常实用的一种经世致用的一种逻辑。
[主播] 我们是要通过思考这些逻辑问题，先把自己生活过明白。
[主播] 再把这个国家治理明白。
[主播] 所以这就是我们的聪明。
[主播] 我觉得我觉得这是一种聪明。
[主播] 我觉得这是一种聪明。
[主播] 当然大家也可以保留不同的观点啊。
[主播] 咱有那个中国哲学史的吗？
[主播] 找到了没？
[主播] 中国哲学史那套书。
[嘉宾] 中国哲学史。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 如果你能找到你可以上。
[主播] 然后呢在汉代的末，当然大家知道这个佛教传入中国。
[主播] 我们也用了几乎几百年的时间把它最后彻底的用汉字解释清楚了。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我们最后也把它实际应用到我们的这个实际生活中了。
[主播] 大家会后来会发现
[主播] 修炼是什么？
[主播] 修炼就是戒嗔，戒痴，戒贪。
[主播] 我们最终是用它来抵挡自己的心灵了。
[主播] 所以我觉得这是一种智慧啊。
[主播] 为我所用啊。
[主播] 广泛吸收为我所用，对不对？
[主播] 这是不是叫听别所有人的意见，保留自己的判断，是不是那个意思？
[主播] 我之前给大家说过听所有人的意见，保留自己的判断，其实就是在中国传统哲学的发展历史中，你就能看到的。
[主播] 我们是充分的去吸收，但是仍然有自己的主心骨。
[主播] 实用主义是一种高级智慧。
[主播] 接地气很重要。
[主播] 然后接下来大家知道到了这个从宋以后再到了明，其实这种心学就开始逐渐的发展。
[主播] 那到了阳明性王阳明的时候，几乎已经我认为达到一个巅峰了。
[主播] 因为在直到明的时候，我们主要的历史的潮流和主要的历史力量都是大部分掌握在或者或者平均的分布在文官的手里头。
[主播] 这点很重要，就是文官如果是民族几量，读书人在掌握历史命运的时候，
[主播] 文人精神就可以传承，所以文人对于哲学的思考可以传承。
[主播] 但是大家后来痛苦的发现
[主播] 因为满清入关之后，它是骑射从文明的发展角度去说，它其实是稍微弱于明的，对吗？
[主播] 坦诚来说啊。
[主播] 所以你会发现到了清的时候，大家对于以前哲学的讨论突然断层了。
[主播] 而且又因为封闭，所以我们几乎慢慢都回世界了。
[嘉宾] 晚清18有。
[主播] 晚清做18年有了是吧？
[主播] 有多少套？
[嘉宾] 现在链接是800。
[主播] 800套，那你上吧。
[主播] 800套估计都不用说。
[主播] 现在直播间里有30几万人，3万人呢。
[主播] 所以这就是为什么要读历史。
[主播] 历史完了以后，接下来下个就可以去读哲学了。
[主播] 当然哲学这块，哎。
[主播] 今天我在图书号他们还有一个叫查拉图斯特拉如是说那本书呢。
[嘉宾] 那本应该有，我找一下。
[主播] 你你问一下。
[主播] 查拉图斯特拉如是说。
[主播] 就是尼采后来从大学离开之后，然后呢住在山洞里写的那个。
[主播] 读哲学也得讲究一个顺序啊。
[主播] 我比较建议，如果大家以前从来没有读过这个书的话啊。
[主播] 就是那个初心，如果你想听那段，我再说明一下，你可以录一下。
[主播] 就是正确的初心才是最强大的力量。
[主播] 我说的主要原因是因为在晚清组18年，这第一，第一版当时有四本的，这一次好像是改版了，改成两本了。
[主播] 改成两本了。
[主播] 我记得我当时在读到这套书的时候，就是很生气。
[主播] 就是明明当时买了那么多特别好的炮，但是那些人在战场上犹豫不决，你想都打仗呀，你还想着这场仗我不能把敌人彻底打输，打输了没有了外部威胁的时候，
[主播] 内部的朝廷的这力量就不均衡了。
[主播] 我也不能彻底把自己打没。
[主播] 打没了之后，李中堂就没那么大的发言权，就你痛恨，你们怎么这么愚腐，你是军人，你不考虑军人的问题。
[主播] 失败是注定的。
[主播] 我在哪一天推这套书，就是我们前天正好有个好消息。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我们这个要什么什么号开始服役了。
[主播] 哇。
[主播] 终于我们。
[主播] 一发过去的耻辱。
[主播] 我那天特别兴奋，我为什么那天选出推这套书？
[主播] 我觉得特别好。
[主播] 我觉得我们可能会步入迷途一段时间，但我们不会始终错误。
[主播] 因为这个民族一个非常强大的力量，就是不断地去自我批判与反思。
[主播] 就像海手强大的能力是什么？它会不断地去洗刷干净自己。
[主播] 你现在扔到海里头的垃圾，如果人类不在那里头扔，或者人类停上，把人类停上，你发海就干净了。
[主播] 大家会发现去年欧洲也当时停所有人都不能出门的时候，发现大家以前去的威尼斯，对吧，那都是处水沟，你平时去，那水都干净了，都能看见小鱼了，甚至海豚都过来了。
[主播] 大自然有极强的清洁能力，我们有极强的自我批判与反思能力。
[主播] 所以这就是为什么
[主播] 这套书特别好。
[主播] 这套书还有没？
[嘉宾] 晚清做18年。
[主播] 没了。
[主播] 行吧，行吧，行吧。
[主播] 那明朝那些事还有没？
[嘉宾] 明朝有。
[主播] 还有多少本？
[主播] 多少套？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 对，谢谢啊。
[主播] 如果这些书还有的话，给大家提醒一下，然后想拍的自己去拍。
[嘉宾] 明朝还有很多。
[主播] 还有很多。
[主播] 那需要明朝那些事。
[主播] 这这这个书很多人觉得太多了，觉得贵。
[主播] 其实你平均到每一本书并不贵。
[主播] 而且因为它趣味性极强。
[主播] 我有理由相信你会跟我一样翻开来之后， you just couldn't simply put it down，你就把书就放不下来了。
[主播] 什么叫喜欢的放不下来？
[主播] 你读一遍就知道了。
[主播] 而且它因为特别的可读性强，所以你其实可以跟自己孩子一块去读的。
[主播] 经典，真的是经典。
[主播] 查拉图斯特拉如是说有没？
[嘉宾] 正在找。
[主播] 查拉图斯特拉和如是说和这个中国哲学史，如果你能找到你就找一下，好吧？
[主播] 然后呢，接下来就是读哲学。
[主播] 这就是董老师回到你读书的一个一个方式啊，并不一定对，好吧，我只是给大家分享一下。
[主播] 我我在当时读哲学的时候，一开始我选错了，坦诚来说。
[主播] 我一开始就选了一个不太好的开头。
[主播] 我在一开始选了先选了书本华，尴尬了。
[主播] 书本华大家知道是个富二代。
[主播] 衣食无忧。
[主播] 他不需要去刻苦的劳动的时候，他就无法体会生命的那个苦难。
[主播] 他也不需要在社会中摸爬滚打的时候，他自然无法体会人情的很多冷暖。
[主播] 因为书本华是个富二代。
[主播] 他爸去世的早。
[主播] 他后来跟妈妈产生了矛盾，刚才吵架，妈妈把他从楼梯上推了下去。
[主播] 他后来也基本断绝了母子关系。
[主播] 他一生都很富裕。
[主播] 所以长期百无聊赖。
[主播] 当然他的哲学其实很深刻，我我刚才这解释有点浅薄，他的哲学很深刻。
[主播] 然后他第一次写的书有吗？
[嘉宾] 查拉图上周才有。
[主播] 上周才有。
[主播] 行吧，那直播间的朋友请点击左上角关注我们。
[主播] 这里是于老师带队新方转型给大家推荐好的平台叫做东方甄选。
[主播] 我是这个董宇辉啊。
[主播] 我一开始就是因为先看了书本华，结果把自己看得特别丧，特别低迷。
[主播] 因为书本华非常经典的名言，大家知道。
[主播] 财富如海水，喝得越多，你越渴。
[主播] 财富如海水，海水肯定要那么咸，越喝越渴，对吧？
[主播] 越喝你越渴。
[主播] 越喝越渴，你越喝。
[主播] 恶性循环了就。
[主播] 年轻的时候我觉得那我得佛系一下。
[主播] 还有他说的人生如中摆在痛苦和无聊之间反复徘徊，欲望得到了满足就无聊，得不到满足就痛苦。
[主播] 你看是不是说的好真实啊？
[主播] 有一个人曾经给我特别有意思的定义，叫什么叫做贵族，什么叫做高级感？
[主播] 就是欲望得到满足之后的倦怠。
[主播] 想吃吃饱了，烫那那种。
[主播] 那就叫做那种贵族气质。
[主播] 就是欲望被满足之后产生的倦怠感。
[主播] 你不能理解那些又渴又饿的人们那种想要活下去的极强的渴望。
[主播] 所以我其实是建议大家，如果你是读西方，你可以从你才开始。
[主播] 超人哲学。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 超人精神。
[主播] 我觉得他跟我们的很多观点是极其相似的。
[主播] 他是能够接受这个苦难之后给人带来的精神成长的。
[主播] 他不至于像之前很多人不接地气，当然你才在西方的哲学历史上也算是一个奇葩，对吧？
[主播] 他一站出来就写了这个悲剧的诞生，然后就去否定苏格拉底。
[主播] 就像现在一个当老师的站出来先否定孔子一样。
[主播] 那你不被骂死，那就怪了。
[主播] 他就是一站出来先去否定了西方历史上2000年人们都从不敢怀疑的苏格拉底。
[主播] 但是你才的书真的我觉得能是给普通人力量的。
[主播] 而且你才一生过得很惨很惨，对吧？
[主播] 24岁到34岁在大学教书，因为28岁出版了那个悲剧的诞生里头批判了这个苏格拉底。
[主播] 他说当清醒的哲人代替了最的诗人，从次九神精神就没落，他就论九神精神与日神精神嘛，对吧？
[主播] 开始被大家所诟病。
[主播] 他以前那么火。
[主播] 后来被人诟病，然后呢离开了大学。
[主播] 34岁到44岁前后左右，南北南北的跑，冬天呢往南方跑，夏天往北方跑，住在山洞里头写书。
[主播] 然后呢他从山洞里出来，去了这个意大利图林街头，看见了车夫用鞭子抽自己的马之后，他就突然想到了自己看到了这个托尔斯泰自己那个罪与罚里头。
[主播] 相同的情节，用鞭子抽白马。
[主播] 他突然就疯了，上去抱著马说，我受苦受难的兄弟啊。
[主播] 然后晕倒了。
[主播] 然后警察就把他带走了，报警了。
[主播] 从44岁到54岁那十年里，大家觉得他是疯的。
[主播] 没有人理解他。
[主播] 54岁他去世了。
[主播] 他短暂的生命里头进行过如此痛苦的深刻的思考。
[主播] 我觉得你才是可以先读的。
[主播] 然后等你读完你才你再去看书本华，你就能稍微理解点。
[主播] 你看完的书本华，你再去看跟书本华当时这个对吧，那么到一块的黑格尔。
[主播] 当然黑格尔和书本华看完了之后，你再去看康德，你发现康德是真的牛，纯理性批判。
[主播] 你根本无法质疑他。
[主播] 逻辑非常完整。
[主播] 你看完了这些，你再去往之前学院派古典派的去看。
[主播] 这个是关于西方的。
[主播] 我们也有一本书给大家找到的叫中国哲学史，对吧？
[主播] 这本书现在不能上，对不对？
[主播] 但是有这本书，对吧？
[主播] 大家稍等一下，点击这里关注我们。
[主播] 过两天我们给大家上这本书叫中国哲学史。
[主播] 中国哲学史这本书已经给大家找到了，大家稍等啊。
[主播] 中国哲学史。
[主播] 等你看到这个，你就能理解我们是如何从当年的这个八出百家独尊儒术，后来到了这个佛以及佛教以及各种综合的思想潮流里头，找到了如何在痛苦现实里找清楚自己的问题，解决自己的问题，并且提出自己的理论观点的一个过程了。
[主播] 我觉得我们是朴实的，我们是讲究实用的。
[主播] 也因此是浪漫的。
[主播] 所以我一直的观点是什么？
[主播] 烟火气就是浪漫气。
[主播] 你不要总是喜欢那些抬头给你看看星仰望星空的人。
[主播] 他有一个人仰望星空，在农业社会的意味著得有99个人低头去从事农业劳作，给他去捡六便士。
[主播] 那仰望星空的人是浪漫呀。
[主播] 抬头看月亮的人是浪漫。
[主播] 浪漫人都不一般都不靠谱。
[主播] 所以你得庆幸那些能够陪你一起去捡六便士的人啊。
[主播] 他有时候沉默。
[主播] 不善言辞。
[主播] 但那是幸福的事情。
[主播] 你很幸运好吗？
[主播] 就是因为他捡了六便士，你才抬头看了月亮。
[主播] 所以这个是关于到了哲学这里。
[主播] 那哲学这本书我们还在给大家找。
[主播] 因为平常这类书可能大家真的不怎么看。
[主播] 我们联系了很多出版社，出版社也说平常哪有这种书？
[主播] 平常谁买这书呢？
[主播] 买不到。
[主播] 所以现在突然我们在直播间里讲了这些，大家愿意看的时候，突然发现一时竟然找不到书。
[主播] 所以现在只能去大量的给大家找。
[主播] 哪个可读性强？
[主播] 明朝这些事这套书。
[主播] 非常的有意思。
[主播] 我是英语老师，我是英语老师，不好意思。
[主播] 我是英语老师。
[主播] 月亮六便士有吗？
[主播] 毛姆的。
[嘉宾] 找一下。
[主播] 加谬的书咱也能找一些，导演你记一下。
[嘉宾] 加谬的。
[主播] 加谬。
[主播] 对，局外人啊，属意啊等等，这些都可以找。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 萨特，大家现在看萨特的人。
[主播] 我不知道咱直播间有人看萨特没？
[主播] 月亮六便士这个如果有的话，你直接上，好吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 这个暂时没有。
[主播] 这个也没有是吧？
[主播] 行吧，行吧。
[主播] 如果能看书，能长时间聊书，那可真太幸福了。
[主播] 因为我曾经就是个老师，对吧，我可能其他本事也没有。
[主播] 你说懂道理，那确实能说一点。
[主播] 你要说我要那些道理能过好自己一生，那我也确实真的办不到。
[主播] 但只要说在镜头前给大家这，对吧，一番卖弄，夸夸其谈，胡说八道。
[主播] 那我还是很喜欢。
[主播] 不一定擅长，可能只是胆大敢而已。
[主播] 如果说得不好也欢迎大家提出各种批评意见。
[主播] 所以我刚就提到了从小说到传记到历史到哲学，但是如果把这些都看完了之后，你还可以看什么书呢？
[主播] 你可以看一些比如说自然科学呀，社会科学的问题。
[嘉宾] 枪炮细菌与钢铁。
[主播] 哎，那个很好，谈一下，直接谈。
[嘉宾] 许先生的。
[主播] 许先生的作品啊。
[主播] 自然科学和社会科学类的书。
[主播] 大家知道当你能够去写下面这类书的时候，你自己本身关于很多专业知识的积累是极其
[主播] 庞大的，体系必须是完整且复杂的。
[主播] 所以为什么后来我会要求我的学生们读完上面书之后，让他们去看人类简史。
[主播] 让他们去看杠子，那套书咱有吧？
[嘉宾] 哪个？
[主播] 枪炮细菌与钢铁。
[嘉宾] 查一下。
[主播] 那个有，因为今天在图书号都上了。
[主播] 最后我们让孩子们去看那些，我们就从关注一个人
[主播] 悲欢喜乐。
[主播] 从关注一个人，有吗？
[主播] 从关注一个人本身他的性格上的优缺，然后我们到了关注一个民族一段历史。
[主播] 我们也通过关注一段民族的一段历史，让自己更加理性周全的去理解那个时代所处的人，他们本身的局限性。
[主播] 也让我们理解了那个时候他们面临的一些抉择之前自己所做的勇气与坚持。
[主播] 最后我们通过一个哲学的高度给自己建立了一个相对完整的价值观体系。
[主播] 你发现这个很重要啊。
[主播] 每一步的铺垫都不可少。
[主播] 我让孩子们看这些，他是不是就成为了一个有悲悯心，有共情能力的人，对不对？
[主播] 然后把这些看完了之后，他接下来再去理解那些看那些名人的传记。
[主播] 他是不是就知道自己要成为什么人了？
[主播] 他之后有了勇气，有了智慧，有了悲悯心，有了共情力，他能够不仅成为一个很好的个体，他甚至能够成为一个有领袖能力，有领袖气质，带领人类向前的时候，
[主播] 在他去读历史，他能够带人类去穿越周期。
[主播] 他能够读哲学的时候，就能解决更长远的个人价值存在问题。
[主播] 有的时候人只是面前不困惑。
[主播] 但人无远，人无近忧，必有远虑啊。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 人无近忧，必有远虑。
[主播] 你发现很多人现在生活都很很幸福。
[主播] 你往后在倒个十年。
[主播] 他说得苦在未来呢。
[主播] 而且如果他的价值观体系或者他的哲学体系不完整的话，他在面临一些痛苦的时候，他不知道怎么抉择，他不知道怎么判断。
[主播] 他就难受，他就痛苦。
[主播] 他一定得考虑这个问题。
[主播] 那如果这些他都已经考虑完了，他已经完整到强大到这个程度的时候，他应该去看那些书了。
[主播] 他应该去了解一个整个大的文明，或者一片土地，或者一个国家一个民族是怎么兴起的。
[主播] 我们得知道25万年前智人是如何从东非走到现在的。
[主播] 我们更得知道700万年前黑猩猩与我们的祖先分开，我们是一路为何走到今天的。
[主播] 我们得知道自己在追捕着猎物，采摘着果实的时候，应该还有着一些崇高。
[主播] 700万年前黑猩猩与我们的祖先分开，我们是一路为何走到今天的。
[主播] 我们得知道自己在追捕的猎物，采摘的果实的时候，应该还有着一些崇高的精神追求。
[主播] 只有我们的子孙能够丰富、强大、智慧到这种程度的时候，才能让他们去解决人类未来会出现的更多的更多的问题。
[主播] 粮食问题。
[主播] 气候问题。
[主播] 疾病问题。
[主播] 贫富差异问题。
[主播] 战争问题。
[主播] 它不能是偏颇的。
[主播] 它不能如现在网上有些人一样，不明就里，群起攻之。
[主播] 它更不能是懦弱的，荒谬的，脆弱的，它也不能是愚蠢的。
[主播] 它可能被人误导，被人利用。
[主播] 所以我之前给大家说过，我说没有人文的科学呢，是危险的。
[主播] 就他心里不知道什么是对错，但他拿了一个非常强大的武器，他会可能会做出非常害怕人的事情，对吗？
[主播] 然后没有科学的人文是愚昧的。
[主播] 他只知道善恶，他只是能看见别人的痛苦而难过，看到别人的好运而开心。
[主播] 但他不知道怎么去解决现实中的问题，他就会容易被人诱导和利用。
[主播] 所以没有科学的人文是愚昧的，没有人文的科学是危险的。
[主播] 这就是一个完整的我自己这么多年读书的一个框架，但是呢，不一定对，也不一定合理，仅仅是我自己的习惯而已。
[主播] 那你说的说里头，你把所有的矛盾文学系列刷个遍，你把诺贝尔文学系列刷个遍，你刷一遍啊。
[主播] 你先看。
[主播] 你你全买回来，挑你喜欢看的。
[主播] 你觉得太多了，那你去书店你借着看也行。
[主播] 书店不让借，那你就在书店里看。
[主播] 总比你整天去逛商场蹦低有意思。
[主播] 总比你整天去迎来送往，端茶倒水，跟人这个在酒桌上吹牛有意思。
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[主播] 读这些比那有意思多了，好吗？
[主播] 只只有我们让大家大量去阅读的时候，你的精神逐渐开始丰富。
[主播] 当精神开始丰富的时候，你就不至于会把所有的精力，和短暂的生命苦苦追寻那些现实中本来可能是靠运气的的东西。
[主播] 董宇辉如果不是把自己时间大量用来阅读的时候，他就想不通，他就会整天在想，我什么时候能火呀，我为什么学不了别人那种表演，我为什么就不能让直播间里有超过一万人，我们那会直播间里有个一千人，我都有个两千人，三千人我开心跟啥样。
[主播] 那如果我沿着错误的路线苦苦思索，我只会离正确的结果越来越远。
[主播] 这过程正确，结果才能正确。
[主播] 这句话非常重要，过程正确，结果才能正确，就你追寻的事情是什么，对不对？
[主播] 还有一个就是让我们的孩子，让我们的子孙大量的阅读之后，才能寻找未来社会人类的精神家园啊。
[主播] 他们难道真的要如我们一样，每天就只担心着房子、汽车、贷款？
[主播] 那生活的快乐和幸福在哪里呢？
[主播] 难道生命只剩下那些了吗？
[主播] 难道在消费主义的捆绑之下，人类只成了去推动经济发展的一个工具了吗？我不认为。
[主播] 我不觉得我们祖先从南从东非走出来，对吧，是为了让我们去过这种无趣的生活的，我我不觉得。
[主播] 我觉得人文一定会闪出它的光。
[主播] 你看我们现在不就成功了吗？
[主播] 知道阶段性成功了，你看我们直播间里现在就有几十万人现在在线听董宇辉在这胡扯淡。
[主播] 有几十万人现在在线愿意去看罗翔法师的精神，有几十万人想要去买毛姆的月亮与六便士，还有前段时间给大家所分享的薛永忠老师的这个唐诗宋词诗经，这个还有吧？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 这个没有的，请每个朋友都买一单。
[主播] 注意，这本书我是非常强烈推荐，请每个人都买一单，你看我推荐有的书是很强势的，比如说像平凡的世界这种书，每个人都买一单。
[主播] 像唐诗宋词诗经，每个人都买一单。
[主播] 我刚才说的是什么？不要偏激狭隘的用自己的观点去审视别人。
[主播] 你看过了足够多的历史之后，你会发现没有人能够通达，也没有人能够周全，也极少有人能够做到真正的理性与智慧。
[主播] 我们都是在那个阶段下的一个小小的历史片段里，存在于自己的信息简房里，什么叫信息简房？就是我知道的，我以为就是全部了。
[主播] 别的事情我不知道，我就以为是错的，我没有见过南极的企鹅，我觉得哪有南极，哪有企鹅，我没有见过北极熊，我觉得没有北极熊，我没有去过火星，我觉得没有火星。
[主播] 我后来觉得只要别人跟我观点不同，别人一定是坏或者是错。
[主播] 这不就是一个信息简房吗？就是就是井底之蛙。
[主播] 那我们时常要去理解不同文化中的优点，每个语言都有每个语言的美，所以许老师给你说了，他的乐趣就是把一种语言的美转化成另一种语言的美。
[主播] 说得多好，我的天，说得多好啊。
[主播] 我们必须承认中文有中文的美。
[主播] 而且坦诚来说，中文的历史流传的比较久，在四大文明里头知道现在中文是没有经过大的这种外敌入侵导致文化断层的，所以语言是一脉发展的，它是一个相对成熟发展的。
[主播] 英语是一个确实发展程度上没有中文那么高的，但我们也不至于就鲁莽的啊，只有中文是美的，当你能这么说的时候，你就跟那个闭关锁国的人差不多了。
[主播] 你跟晚清做18年的人差不多了。
[主播] 时常去提醒自己，不要陷入某种偏激或者是荒谬之中。
[主播] 当一个人都能够这样去自律且自省去思考的时候，我有理由相信我们会把这片土地变成自己心中的理想国。
[主播] 很重要啊，朋友们，千万不敢自嗨。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 罗翔老师那本书还有吗？导演？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 还有多少库存？
[主播] 这本说我也是强烈推荐的，因为我读完之后我发现我特别喜欢法治的细节。
[主播] 我刚说的一个时代的幸运就在于那个时代拥有人那样清醒的人。
[嘉宾] 法治细节还有两万本。
[主播] 还有两万本，真好，这种好书可以多卖一些。
[主播] 大家每每在回回顾这个古希腊的时候，大家就庆幸的发现那个时代有着拥有那个时代的古希腊三杰。
[主播] 我们再看到春秋战国的时候，我们就庆幸的发现了当时有诸子百家。
[主播] 每个时代的人产生之后像一个火把一样，照亮那一篇夜空，让更多迷茫甚至很多时候无知的人们找到一个清晰的方向。
[主播] 这不是一个人文主义陷落的时代，我不相信，法治也属于人文主义，对吗？
[主播] 而且罗翔老师其实火出圈，他并不是因为自己的这个法，他是因为能够通过讲法的时候讲的有趣，而且通过讲法后来反思到人生的很多问题。
[主播] 他是一个极其灵魂清醒的人。
[主播] 我们喜欢跟清醒的人说话，你发现生活中有些人就咋说他都听不懂，他就是在自己的世界里头装傻。
[主播] 你永远叫不醒一个装睡的人，你也永远催眠不了一个清醒的人。
[主播] 你可以记下这句话，我知道很多有朋友现在每天晚上来听董宇辉直播就只是为了记金句，可以。
[主播] 你永远无法催眠一个清醒的人，你也永远无法叫醒一个装睡的人。
[主播] 说得多好。
[主播] 鸡蛋还有吗？导演？
[嘉宾] 没了。
[主播] 没了，那我看看你收，让我再讲一下鸡蛋。
[主播] 我喝口水啊，不好意思，我喝口水可以吗？我我清个嗓子，嗓子有点痰，我害怕影响你们的这个体验。
[主播] 好，现在应该好了，我我刚这个把这个话筒临时关了一下，我特别害怕影响到大家的体验。
[嘉宾] 什么在二号？
[嘉宾] 白水山。
[主播] 白水山，这个水。
[主播] 这个水我前天喝了一瓶，然后我觉得这个瓶子挺厚的，扔了挺可惜，我就拿这个瓶子一直从我们饮水机里灌水喝。
[主播] 这个里头不是白水山的水，是我从饮水机里灌的水。
[主播] 但是它能用啊。
[主播] 我以前经常就是。
[主播] 我比如用一个塑料瓶子的话，因为我平常喝水那个杯子太重了。
[主播] 而且我比较笨，经常容易丢到高铁上，我之前高铁飞机上每次都会丢杯子，我后来就出门平常自己有塑料瓶我也不扔，拿它一直用就行。
[主播] 咱接下来给大家继续带下一个产品啊，我们现在还有这个，还有啥货，快快快，还有啥货？
[嘉宾] 牛奶。
[主播] 牛奶来了，牛奶牛奶牛奶。
[主播] 特仑苏特仑苏。
[嘉宾] 八米还有吗？
[主播] 八米没有了，卖完了。
[主播] 没有了，早都没有了。
[主播] 来来来，特仑苏牛奶啊。
[主播] 大家来点来点身体这个这个食粮啊，别别一直就精神世界了，快快快，接地接地气一点啊，快。
[主播] 两箱特仑苏，一箱这个纯真牛奶。
[主播] 导演你现在可以给放点背景音乐，要不然大家容易枯燥，因为我刚讲那段实在太枯燥了，我害怕把有的朋友说已经成功的睡着了。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 有朋友说节俭。
[主播] 其实不是节俭，我是觉得如果自己少用一点塑料的话，我应该是在做一件善事吧。
[主播] 嗯，我觉得少用点塑料应该是做一件好事，能不用尽量都不用，坦诚来说。
[主播] 其实我平常出门都是拿个水杯去接水，有的时候水杯真的丢了，我没有办法，我只能买个这样塑料瓶子用用一段时间。
[主播] 它跟这个节俭关系不大，坦诚来说，你说节俭节俭那那能省多少钱，省不了多少钱。
[主播] 但是我特别害怕，我时常给大家提一种现象，我之前说过，我说如果有一天等我老了，我的子孙站在我面前质问我说，爷爷为什么现在到处都是塑料，你你们那一代人为什么用这么多塑料，现在所有的小动物的尸体里都是塑料，海里头都是塑料，山里都是塑料，河里也都是塑料，为什么你们要弄那么多塑料？
[主播] 我怕我到时候无言以对，我不知道羞愧的不知道怎么回答我的子孙。
[主播] 或者大家按照知道现在按照的速度，其实北极熊可能赶本世纪末其实就消失了，按照现在英国一些科学家们的一个预测的速度。
[主播] 我再想如果那时候孩子们只能看到北极熊标本的时候，他们会不会问我呀？
[主播] 他们会不会恨我呀？
[主播] 我我有时候会想这种问题啊。
[主播] 接下来给大家带来的是这个莫小奇的黑枸杞。
[主播] 酸甜口感，非常的舒服。
[主播] 我给大家展示一下里头的样子啊。
[主播] 刚刚讲讲讲那些书，如果大家还想买的话，自己买啊，我我得赶紧开始营业了。
[主播] 一盒里头有有十包，每一包是30毫升，所以一盒是300毫升。
[主播] 一这一大袋里头有三盒，再送了一小盒。
[主播] 具体的这个规格大家可以点开这个链接看一下，行不行？
[主播] 我我们这中我好像把那盒拆了给大家让大家喝了，我先说不全了。
[主播] 这个品牌叫奇力香，枸杞里的香，奇力香。
[主播] 我特别喜欢奇力香周杰伦那首歌，他跟田中千绘拍的MV。
[主播] 我喜欢那个人们比较青涩的年代里，那个时候的歌手都是认真的写自己的词，写写自己的曲，而不是靠很多的东西去上热搜。
[主播] 那个时候人们会害羞的站在稻田里，认真的虽然字都咬不清，但是他认真唱情歌的样子，我觉得很有魅力，很有美感。
[主播] 而且奇力香也是石木石木隆你个诗集啊，如果你读过的话。
[主播] 想的朋友自己去拍了啊。
[主播] 黑黑枸杞，这个还是挺好喝的，酸甜的口感，你给我个杯子我给大家展示一下吧，我赶快卖回货，要不然我这个工作保不住了。
[嘉宾] 对对对。
[主播] 好，大家可以看到啊，这个哎呀，你给了个颜色深的，大家看不到这个颜色。
[主播] 你看，这是正常的这个枸杞的汁，它就是这个蓝色的，这个蓝色其实就是花青素的颜色，看到了没有？
[主播] 然后它是酸甜的口感，它的配料里头只有这个黑枸杞，没有其他的东西。
[主播] 很干净啊。
[主播] 我我刚说的那些书应该右下角都还有吧，导演？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 有，你把那些都谈一下，然后刚才没有买的朋友，答应我，都买些书好吗？
[主播] 而且我也给大家说了，就是你可以，比如说你穿的衣服上简单一些，其实这个不重要，董宇辉一下天其实就三件四件白短袖，晚上洗，然后换着穿穿一下天。
[主播] 然后我这身上四个裤子还是去年在那个啥里买的，就是大家平常买那种特别便宜的时尚的这种快时尚的品牌就买的，我都穿了几年了。
[主播] 就是职业没有区别，但是快乐确实是有高低之分的，我举个例子，比如你特别爱书，那你读完一本书带来的喜悦，可能就比你请别人请你吃一顿饭带来的喜悦要多，对吗？
[主播] 比如说你是一个乐于助人的人，那你帮完了一个人，那个喜悦可能就比你买件衣服的喜悦要多。
[主播] 我是觉得你精神上的丰富应该给你带来的快乐会更直接，因为我相信每一个人精神世界是需要那种去需要慰藉的，我们需要寻求自己的精神家园。
[主播] 就像苏东坡所说的那样，粗增大不果生崖，富有诗书气自华。
[主播] 你看粗增大不，粗增大不果着不冷就行了，干净体面就行了，对不对？
[主播] 如果我整天是一个靠穿衣服打扮自己的男生，可能你也不一定喜欢我的，粗增大不果生崖，富有诗书气自华，当然我说的主要原因也是因为没钱买衣服。
[主播] 而且我穿的衣服呢之后我发现糟蹋那钱干啥？
[主播] 别人衣服要体现出美感，知道都有一定的腿的长度和线条。
[主播] 我整个身高一米四。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 头50厘米，糟蹋东西，我就没有必要花那个钱了。
[主播] 黑枸杞原浆，喜欢的朋友自己去拍啊。
[主播] 牛奶，这个是两箱鲜奶，还有一箱酸奶，总共加起来一共是34盒，100多块钱，平均下来一盒大概是3块3毛5。
[主播] 特仑苏的牛奶3块3毛5,其实你就用了一个你买了一个 quality milk, average price,你用了一个普通牛奶的价格买了一罐高品质牛奶，大概是这个意思啊。
[主播] 赶快赶快工作，带货带货，不扯淡了。
[主播] 这个高品质牛奶叫 quality milk。
[主播] 这个笔写不下来，导演。
[主播] 那个黑颜色的笔写不下来，你一会重找一个好吗？
[主播] quality milk,用蓝色写的，大家可能眼睛看着不舒服。
[主播] quality milk,写错了， quality milk。
[主播] So you can buy this quality milk at a lower price,用一个更低的价格， at a lower price, low叫低， lower叫更低的 price。
[主播] 那我们一般说普通的牛奶或者普通的商品怎么说呢？
[主播] 普通的汽车，普通的房子，大家一说到普通，大家第一反应是 common,对吧，或者叫 usual,其实你可以用这个词叫 average,平均数，就是正常的，普通的，普通的牛奶，你可以说 average milk,就是我们平常所买一种普通的牛奶。
[主播] 那 quality milk和这个 average milk之间的区别啥？其实就是他们里头的这个蛋白质的含量的区别，OK?
[主播] The differ或者 the differences。
[主播] The differences in什么呀？ in protein content, content叫含量，所以 quality milk和 average milk其实主要的区别就是在蛋白质含量上的区别，OK?
[主播] The differences in protein content。
[主播] 牛奶啊，你你你当然可以，你说那我买普通牛奶，我喝两罐是不是也行？可以。
[主播] 但也不是说早餐人一次就能喝两罐牛奶，你要喝能下去能行，那家里的老人或者是孩子他胃口不一定好。
[主播] 你像董宇辉这种，对吧？
[主播] 我现在连喝一罐牛奶都费劲了，这两天。
[主播] 胃口越来越差。
[主播] 来，想要的朋友自己去拍啊，这个纯真的酸奶，口感也特别好。
[主播] 因为大家都是在超市里买过的，比如一箱你平常买都是六七十，现在在我们直播间里三箱才100多，其实就是好东西，只要价格实惠，家里又每天都常用常喝，对不对？
[主播] 爱有时候不只是说要这种温声细语的表达。
[主播] 爱其实更多在我们的理解里头，反而是在三餐四季的陪伴。
[主播] 爱是他晚上睡觉的时候给他盖好的被子，爱是他早上出门的时候，书包侧兜里给他放着的牛奶和玉米。
[主播] 爱更多时候是生活中的细节。
[主播] 这个枸杞，黑枸杞的汁也很好喝，大家如果没有尝过可以试一下。
[主播] 酸甜口感，而且它里头含的这个花青素和氨基酸比较多啊。
[主播] 接下来还有这个大西洋鳕鱼块。
[主播] cod,大西洋鳕鱼。
[主播] 这个就是鳕鱼，它叫大西洋，这个叫对，太平洋真鳕鱼，它不是大家平常所说的那个银鳕鱼。
[主播] 那种鱼的价格已经高到离谱了，我们这里卖的都是一些比较日常的吃的。
[主播] 如果您是想要那个特别那高价格的那个银鳕鱼的话，那您别买这个，因为这个确实它不是。
[主播] 这个鳕鱼片很大，大家可以在锅里头稍微煎一下，然后撒上一些香料，或者直接上锅蒸一下，蒜拌肉，煮火锅也可以。
[主播] 很多人都是给家里的老人或者小孩买辅食，因为鱼的一个白白肉嘛，对吧，它的一个特点是什么？就是蛋白质含量高，脂肪含量低，对于人体来说是一个非常好营养补充的元素。
[主播] OK,想要的朋友自己去拍啊，黑枸杞不是不是纯甜也不是纯酸，它是酸甜感。
[主播] 这个是酸甜感啊，黑枸杞。
[主播] 酸酸甜甜的还是挺喜欢的。
[主播] 年少时候我们都特别喜欢甜，长大之后受了很多苦就喜欢吃酸。
[主播] 再后来发现其实你既不喜欢纯甜，你也不喜欢纯酸，太甜了忧伤，太酸了痛苦，你终于找到了一个适合自己的酸甜比。
[主播] 不管是水果还是说这些喝的东西，你找到一个适合自己的酸甜比就特别好。
[主播] 就比如说为什么莫希托会非常受很多人欢迎呢？因为他酸甜比很好。
[主播] 他不是一味的苦苦到让你难受，他也不是一味的甜甜到你甜的觉得不真实，酸甜比例掌握得很好。
[主播] 呃。
[主播] 银鳕鱼，哇，这个票大，这个超大的票，大家看到了吗？
[主播] 银鳕鱼。
[主播] 犬牙鱼啊，这是写的。
[主播] 如果是大家平常喜欢吃的可以做拍一些，这个1000克，可以比如说这个蒸啊，煎啊，煮火锅都可以。
[主播] 我我也不知道怎么做，大家可能比我更专业一些，你看这片多大，这里多大的鱼啊。
[主播] 然后呢，如果你自己在家做的话，你可以去抖音上搜一下有各种各样做的这个方式。
[主播] 我不是特别专业，对不起啊。
[主播] 它的这个生产地，产地为什么有个山东青岛呢？当然鱼不是山东青岛的，鱼是在海里捞出来之后在山东青岛加工的。
[主播] 我们给大家之前推出的很多的像这个虾呀，这个还有特别好的一些鱼，几乎都是在山东青岛，因为青岛是北方最大的这个海产品以及各种各样农产品，甚至一些工业品的进进出口港嘛。
[主播] 几乎都是在山东青岛，因为青岛是北方最大的这个海产品以及各种各样农产品
[主播] 甚至一些工业品的进口港吗？
[主播] 青岛和黄岛嘛，如果有当地朋友大家都知道。
[主播] 很多的工业品、农产品其实都是在青岛入的港。
[主播] 所以入港之后就地就找一个工厂了，它其实就很大程度能够带动当地的就业了。
[主播] 要中国哲学史，中国哲学史那本书今天没有对吧？
[主播] 嗯，还有朋友说要什么？
[其他] 今天没有。
[主播] 如果你想买的书，您关注我们直播间啊。
[主播] 谢谢。
[主播] 我们也会按照，当然我的观点不一定对啊，我也时常在这里首先自我批评做反思。
[主播] 我会按照我之前读书的很多的方式给大家去继续寻找，这只是一个开始。
[主播] 我们不可能一生只读这几本书。
[主播] 然后接下来给大家来了一个翡翠生虾人。
[主播] 读书读的少，本本都是好，对吧？
[主播] 我们就这一点书是不可能想明白人生的很多问题的。
[主播] 我们这一点点偏颇而荒谬的观点也不可能去指导别人的人生。
[主播] 我们这一点点所拥有的知识和智慧也很难去解决人生未来所有的问题。
[主播] 有一件事是确定的。
[主播] 就是就于老师所说的，你终将会离开这个世界。
[主播] 这个里头之前我们卖的虾人里头有比较多的那个冰的包衣，然后有的朋友反应那个咸虾人小，咸那个包衣有点多。
[主播] 但不确定的是你在什么时候以什么方式离开这个世界。
[主播] 那同样在看书这件事情是确定是，有一件事确定就是你肯定是要一直持续去阅读的。
[主播] 阅读很多时候我并不是为了直接，你读书那我读这书对我有什么用？
[主播] 对我工作有什么用？能不能让我赚钱？
[主播] 你要这样想的话，你还不如不读了，朋友。
[主播] 如果你一直在这样问我的话，那你还不如不读了。
[主播] 你就继续去纠结现实中的很多问题，你就继续精神空虚，然后思想匮乏。
[主播] 就像我前几天讲的，为什么于老师要求新东方老师读书呢？
[主播] 如果你一个老师，你自己都不读几本书，你精神那么匮乏，你如何去触碰另一个灵魂啊？
[主播] 你一张嘴就让人感觉到你没有深度，你怎么能够吸引别人啊？
[主播] 你都没有办法旁征博引，深入浅出，微妙微笑，谁愿意听你啊？
[主播] 大概就是这种意思。
[主播] 对不起，我今天上来卖货其实没有卖货，我一直在扯扯著一些扯了很多。
[主播] 书也没有卖几本，是吧？
[其他] 卖钱。
[主播] 我今天卖多少本书？
[主播] 那我们就给大家找了这个，当然你你的这个虾人含量多少不一样，它的价格其实也就不一样了。
[主播] 我刚在带货的时候有排名吗？
[主播] 没有是吧？
[其他] 带货榜上。
[主播] 一直是啊。
[主播] 那也行，那也行。
[主播] 我特别害怕我一卖书，因为其实我在这讲书只是因为个人喜欢而已，我就有时候说下来就不停，有时候就不管别人的体验。
[主播] 直播间里其实很多朋友大家想要买东西，可能我时候信息太多了，因为这有35、6万人。
[主播] 刚才有40多万人呢都。
[主播] 我看不到有时候消息发太快了，我可能给大家回不清楚。
[主播] 对不起。
[主播] 如果您需要，您可以在右下角小黄车里自己去看，自己去买，好不好？
[主播] 我们特别希望这成为一个超市。
[主播] 超市是什么感觉？
[主播] 所以如果你想吃这个的话，你可以试一试。
[主播] 你不仅不慢啊。
[主播] 你跟你的爱人，跟你的孩子推著车，对吧，甚至还把孩子放在车里头，亲一亲他的小脸蛋，摸一摸他的头发。
[主播] 你们不仅不慢的在超市里逛，慢慢挑呢。
[主播] 你觉得呢？
[主播] 那那小黄车其实就是我们这个超市的小货架，您可以挑一挑。
[主播] 我特别不希望您到我们直播间之后，我们弄一个传导的音乐或者那种特别逼得得逼人的这个文字，然后让你尽快下单，恨不得赶快把你再赶出去一样。
[主播] 我也不想那样，你也不舒服嘛，你觉得呢？
[主播] 它的配料表也分干净，来给大家展示一下，导演给个进景，你看它的配料表。
[主播] 你喜欢你可以自己去拍。
[主播] 还有一点，注意，非常重要，叫理性消费，按需购买，钱都不是风刮来的。
[主播] 一旦你
[主播] 一旦你把大量的时间用来或者极多的时间和精力都用来购物的时候，你就其实没有钱了。
[主播] 没有钱，你得花更多时间去工作。
[主播] 花更多时间工作的时候，你其实就没有时间去读书，陪孩子去体验自然的归复神功。
[主播] The only ingredients are shrimp and water, nothing else, okay?就这两个东西，虾人和水。
[主播] 你本来是为了快乐去买东西消费的，结果你最后却因此丧失掉了快乐。
[主播] 你说呢？
[主播] 好，现在导演还有什么，我再我再给大家说一个吧。
[主播] 还需要我再说吗？
[主播] 导演可以啊，因为我我在这说了很多，好像没卖多少钱。
[主播] 我害怕觉得对不起你们。
[主播] 我可能拉低了大家的效率。
[其他] 啊，不影响，不影响。
[主播] 你让我挣点挣点钱吧。
[主播] 呃，这个小面包。
[主播] 办公室里可以吃。
[主播] 然后呢，法式软面包。
[主播] 呃，还有瑞士卷。
[主播] I'm sorry.
[主播] 这这里头还有个粉，粉肯定不是这，还有两块老面包。
[主播] 导演，咱这个是不是得动著，要不然这个样品还会坏了。
[主播] 家里真正做饭的人就知道这个挑虾线，挑虾线去去虾头那些是多么的麻烦。
[主播] 嗯，晚上以后把这个动著，记得。
[主播] 就是这个老面包它肯定是需要动的，啊。
[主播] 要不然时间长了不好。
[主播] 然后呢？
[其他] 啊？
[主播] 对，送一个冰墩墩啊。
[主播] 当时孩子没有要的蹲蹲现在来了，嗯。
[主播] 冰墩墩。
[主播] 到了冰墩墩的话，那马上就有了蹲蹲了。
[主播] 大家喜欢的蹲蹲马上就来了。
[主播] 还有虾条。
[主播] 应该是有两包虾条，我记得，是吧？
[主播] 应该是谁吃了一包。
[主播] 如果您喜欢吃这种的话，可以买一个，到老晚上比如说在家里可以看著东方甄选的直播。
[主播] 或者有时候带孩子去看一本书呀，晚上自己好朋友喝点小酒啊，其实你也可以吃个这个。
[主播] 在家里看个纪录片呀。
[主播] 对不起。
[主播] 大家有时候的平时回答一些问题，问的一些题目我没有办法回答。
[主播] 因为有朋友问的那个，我我好长时间都不看综艺了。
[主播] 我平时也不怎么看综艺。
[主播] 我也没怎么打过游戏，所以我可能回答不了你的一些问题，我刚看那个朋友在问啊。
[主播] 早上起来，比如说你自己要健康早餐，对吧，拿鸡蛋和这个一炒，迅速就好了。
[主播] 这个就是冰墩墩。
[主播] 它会直接放在箱子里对吗？
[主播] OK, yeah, good。
[主播] 它会放在箱子里这个冰墩墩。
[主播] 哦。
[主播] 圆圆的样子，眼睛大大的，像不像盾的。
[主播] 像不像东东？
[主播] 像不像悠悠？
[主播] 像不像七七？
[主播] 像不像我们直播间那些颜值很高的主播？
[主播] 你应该不会想到十名，别怕，到晚上了，不要想那些下人的东西。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 啊，那我就不耽搁大家了。
[主播] 好吧？
[其他] 啊？
[其他] 到半点好吧？
[主播] 到半点，那现在几点？
[其他] 29。
[主播] 29,那我那我再等一分钟。
[主播] 还有还有什么需要我卖的吗？
[其他] 来个意面吧。
[主播] 来意面，好。
[主播] 这个意面的口感很好啊。
[主播] 我们在之前视频的时候吃过一次。
[主播] 因为我我们之前有去欧洲玩过，然后去在欧洲的时候有吃过这个。
[主播] 坦诚来说，它做的口感还是非常好的。
[主播] 或者家里有孩子要上学，著急都要走了，你这个早餐还没有做好，其实就很麻烦。
[主播] 它有川香麻辣番茄牛肉这个意面。
[主播] 然后呢，川香麻辣番茄牛肉酱面。
[主播] 呃，意大利面，知识芝麻风味。
[主播] 还有包什么什么，所以它全部在这个里头了。
[主播] 它后面给你写了有这么多的东西。
[主播] So all together inside this box.
[主播] 它是个纸纸盒子，纸盒子好点吧，我觉得。
[主播] 至少比塑料好点。
[主播] 这个是料包。
[主播] 这个叫奶油培根配白葡萄酒提香意面酱。
[主播] OK。
[主播] And also you have this 法式红酒配图林根风味香肠意面酱。
[主播] And also of course you got this spaghetti, the pasta.
[主播] 啊， salt。
[主播] 那这个时候就拿著这个虾人和鸡蛋炒一下，既方便又营养，好吗？
[主播] Yeah, 海盐。
[主播] And also 橄榄沙粉。
[主播] And still 橄榄油包。
[主播] 所以这些料都在里头了，很方便，你只要把这个煮一下。
[主播] 因为有的时候可能生活中的惊喜就是给自己创造一些不同的食物，不同的心情。
[主播] 也许是一个阳光明媚的早上，你收拾干净了房子。
[主播] 洗干净的衣服挂在阳台上散发出好闻的味道。
[主播] 穿着舒服的衣服，扎起了头发，然后去厨房里耐心的给自己煮了一盘的意大利面，放在干净的白色的盘子里。
[主播] 人间的六月天呢。
[主播] 呃，意大利面。
[主播] OK,导演现在几点？
[其他] 31了。
[主播] 31了，OK。
[主播] 那我们刚说有这个冰墩墩了，接下来就要欢迎真墩墩了啊。
[主播] 有朋友说要杨梅汁，导演有的话给大家谈一下。
[主播] 欢迎真墩墩。
[主播] 是是到你了吗？
[嘉宾] 知道我了。
[嘉宾] 谢谢你多讲了15分钟，让我休息了15分钟。
[嘉宾] 听我说谢谢你。
[嘉宾] 好，各位，哇，这门课太多吃的了吧，真的很幸福。
[主播] OK。
[其他] 杨梅汁，杨梅汁没有。
[主播] 没了。
[其他] 杨梅汁也没有了。
[主播] OK。